bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation et
sur TV 78 épisode ce soir 20044 mon
invité est le député rassemblement
national de l'Eure Kevin moview
[Musique]
politique
Kevin mauvieux bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes donc député à
Rennes de la troisième circonscription
de l'heure en Normandie vous avez 31 ans
vous avez très jeune démarré votre
engagement politique à 18 ans vous
adhérez à l'UMP et devenez militant vous
devenez à 29 ans conseiller municipal
dans votre ville de naissance
Pont-Audemer vous quittez LR en 2020 car
vous jugez que le parti est devenu trop
proche d'Emmanuel Macron vous faites le
choix d'adhérer au rassemblement
national en 2022 l'année dernière la
même année vous êtes élu député et siégé
donc depuis à l'Assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière Kevin ma vieux c'était
le 1er mai fête de la nation organisé
par le RN qui s'est déroulée au Havre
dans votre région en Normandie
l'occasion pour vous j'imagine
d'échanger avec les militants venus de
toute la France plus jeune vous n'aviez
pas choisi ce parti pourquoi aujourd'hui
c'est le parti qui correspond le plus à
vos valeurs mais vous l'avez dit
vous-même alors j'ai commencé à l'UMP
donc partie de droite j'ai toujours été
attaché à la valeur travail à l'autorité
à la fermeté
c'est des valeurs voilà que j'ai
toujours partagées aujourd'hui et depuis
quelques années l'UMP est devenu les
républicains et trop proche pour moi du
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron on l'a vu
vécu et subi d'ailleurs ces derniers
temps avec la réforme des retraites si
rappelons que si elle est passée si
l'émotion de censure a été rejetée c'est
parce que les républicains malgré
quelques courageux les républicains se
sont alliés à la macronie et ont donné
quitus au gouvernement pour continuer sa
politique donc ça donne raison au choix
que j'ai fait maintenant il y a bientôt
trois ans de dire de dire stop de
quitter les républicains et ensuite de
réfléchir effectivement dans le paysage
politique où est-ce que je me situais et
elle rassemblement national aujourd'hui
et Marine Le Pen porte les valeurs que
je défends la valeur travail au centre
du jeu la sécurité la fermeté
la justice sociale
ce sont des valeurs je retrouve
aujourd'hui au RN et le fait donc de
d'organiser cette fête de la nation en
Normandie ce que c'était particulier
pour vous députés de la région ah bah
j'ai été très fier même si c'était pas
ma circonscription j'étais très fier que
Marine et Jordan Bardella et choisit ma
région et en plus la proximité de ma
circonscription parce que j'avais qu'à
passer le pont de Tancarville ou de
Normandie et j'étais au Havre donc il y
avait une certaine fierté est-ce que le
rassemblement national vienne ici
d'autant que la Normandie fait partie de
ces régions qui n'étaient pas du tout
rassemblement national et qui bascule on
le voit avec le département de l'Eure 4
députés sur cinq rassemblement national
donc je pense que c'était important que
un événement national de réconciliation
entre une certaine classe politique
qu'elle rassemblée nationale et le
peuple se passe à Rouen le Wavre pardon
vous avez vécu cette semaine votre
premier 8 mai en tant que député le 8
mai date de la victoire sur l'Allemagne
nazie vous avez participé à plusieurs
cérémonies de commémoration dans votre
circonscription comment est-ce que vous
avez vécu c'est c'est première cérémonie
en tant que que député c'est prenant
quand vous passez de citoyens qui
assistent à une commémoration parce que
vous êtes fier que votre pays ait pu
vaincre la barbarie la cruauté que
représentait l'Allemagne nazie
c'est vous franchissez un câble vous
représentez toute une circonscription
vous représentez la République française
dans cette histoire et de débarquement
exactement et donc avoir cette étiquette
de représentant du peuple à une
commémoration aussi importante que
celle-ci qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
faire cette émission librement de vivre
dans la paix autant que possible c'est
hyper important c'est c'est une fierté
c'est un poids aussi parce qu'on sent
avec l'écharpe tricolores quand on
chante la Marseillaise devant ce
monument et qu'on sait qu'on est lui
mais on sent aussi un poids sur les
épaules et ça nous rappelle la charge
qu'elle a notre mais c'est une grande
fierté alors pendant ce temps le chef de
l'été mais le Macron était lui sur les
Champs-Élysées presque vite quasi vide
vu le contexte les rassemblements et les
manifestations étaient interdites autour
des Champs-Élysées autour d'un dans le
secteur alors après les poignées de
mains aussi au Stade de France ou le
président était obligé donc de saluer
les finalistes dans le couloir c'est une
nouvelle image d'un président coupé du
peuple après la réforme des retraites
comment est-ce que vous vous analysez
c'est ces images est-ce que vous avez
déjà le souvenir de d'un président aussi
aussi isolé alors déjà vous l'avez dit
couper du peuple je pense que c'est le
mot il est bunkerisé
il y a même plus de mots en fait pour
décrire ça c'est à dire qu'on a un
président de la République qui ne peut
plus se montrer en public même sur une
journée aussi importante que lui mais où
on commémore quand même l'Union
nationale la démocratie et la paix face
à la barbarie même ce jour-là il en
vient à mettre un écran géant à côté de
l'Arc de Triomphe pour que les pigeons
dans les arbres puissent le regarder
enfin c'est c'est on va loin quand même
je n'ai que 31 ans mais je n'ai pas de
mémoire d'un président de la République
fêter une fête aussi importante que
celle de la Libération ou que celle de
la victoire plutôt sur l'Allemagne je
n'ai pas de souvenirs d'un président le
faire sur des Champs-Élysées totalement
vide debout dans une voiture à saluer
les barrières enfin c'est c'est quand
même hallucinant mais après c'est
automatique je trouve de la dérive dans
laquelle on est depuis quelques mois
avec Emmanuel Macron qui est une dérive
quasi autoritaire il dit quasi
autoritaire parce qu'évidemment on a
toujours le droit de vote on est
toujours officiellement démocratie mais
on a un président qui ne peut plus
entrer en contact avec le peuple qui
défile tout seul entouré de militaire
avec des images qui sont presque qui
sont presque malaisantes de voir ce
personnage seul au milieu de des
Champs-Élysées nous on le voit en tant
qu'opposition on est bâillonné entre
guillemets à l'Assemblée nationale à
coup de 49-3 on ne peut pas représenter
le peuple comme on le veut parfois on ne
peut pas prendre la parole comme on le
veut parfois on circonscription il y a
des consignes qui sont données les
députés d'opposition pas forcément les
rennes mais d'opposition ne doivent pas
prendre la parole il faut limiter la
parole c'est des choses qu'on retrouve
dans des régimes autoritaires empêcher à
l'opposition de s'exprimer c'est grave
et je pense que cette image du présent
de la République seul dans sa voiture
qui salue les barrières et qui installe
un écran pour des pigeons c'est à la
fois triste et à la fois révélateur on
retourne dans votre région maintenant
l'autoroute A13 a été bloquée donc
c'était au niveau de Val-de-Reuil dans
l'heure des militants du collectif les
soulèvements de la terre ont voulu
montrer leur opposition à un projet de
contournement Est de Rouen au total donc
41,5 km pour cette nouvelle
infrastructure de 2 x 2 voies dont
l'accès sera payant avec donc 9
échangeurs prévus un grand nombre de
viaducs et tranchés dont certaines
seront couvertes et
500 hectares environ seront
artificialisés pour ce projet la mise en
service est annoncée pour 2024 alors les
opposants à ce projet dénoncent donc un
projet qui va à l'encontre des enjeux
environnementaux actuels rond et
cependant la seule ville de cette taille
à ne pas avoir de contournement routier
quel est votre
positionnement sur ce dossier et est-ce
que vous soutenez ces actions ces
blocages alors je vais répondre à la
dernière question qui est la plus simple
non je ne soutiens pas ces blocages je
pense qu'il y a tellement de façons de
manifester son mécontentement de se
faire entendre que de prendre en otage
des centaines de personnes sur une
autoroute très passante à un moment très
passant c'est c'est voilà c'est on les
prend en otage les manifestants se
mettent en danger mettent en danger les
automobilistes et mettre en danger les
forces de l'ordre qui doivent venir qui
doivent intervenir sur l'autoroute donc
non évidemment ça je condamne totalement
ce mode d'action maintenant le
contournement Est de Rouen alors je ne
suis pas dans ce dossier parce que c'est
éloigné de ma circonscription et que je
ne suis pas roané mais je sais qu'il est
attendu depuis très longtemps parce que
non déplaise aux écologistes la voiture
aujourd'hui quand on habite en Normandie
c'est essentiel c'est
incontournable même avec un
contournement c'est incontournable donc
j'ai bien conscience que ça peut poser
les problématiques écologiques j'ai bien
conscience que peut-être le dossier doit
plus être réfléchi plus cette pensée
pour pour limiter au maximum les impacts
environnementaux que ça peut occasionner
mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire aux
habitants des zones rurales aux
habitants de Normandie qui ont besoin
d'aller à Rouen pour aller travailler
moi ça a été mon cas à un moment quand
j'étais étudiant j'allais à Rouen on ne
peut pas leur dire sous prétexte de ne
pas créer de nouvelles routes parce que
ça inciterait les voitures etc on ne
peut pas leur dire de continuer à passer
des heures dans les bouchons d'autant
que ces militants écologistes oublient
une chose c'est que les bouchons ça
polluent parce que vous êtes à l'arrêt
avec un moteur qui tourne vous
redémarrer chaque démarrage d'une
voiture pollue plus qu'une voiture qui
roule en continu ça il oublie aussi donc
il y a pas de solution miracle
aujourd'hui
donc moi je serai plutôt favorable je
pense à ce contournement Est à condition
que le dossier soit correctement ficelé
de bout en bout avec des critères
écologiques peut-être très poussés parce
qu'effectivement on va artificialiser
quand même une très grosse parcelle on
va on va beaucoup artificialiser
maintenant empêcher totalement le
développement des routes c'est
ahurissant et c'est vraiment ne pas
comprendre les problématiques que vivent
les Normands aujourd'hui alors autre
dossier important en termes de transport
et il concerne cette fois également les
Franciliens c'est la ligne nouvelle
Paris Normandie qui reliera donc Paris
Rouen Le Havre et quand est Cherbourg
une promesse qui a été faite par Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2007 un dossier qui traîne en
longueur depuis aujourd'hui
l'aboutissement du projet est prévu pour
2040 mais la présidente LR de la région
Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse s'y
oppose elle reproche à l'état de
dépenser près de 11 milliards d'euros
pour cette lmpn c'est l'abréviation
alors que sa région la région
Île-de-France souffre d'un
sous-investissement en matière de
transport de plus le projet consommera
280 hectares de terres agricole
majoritairement dans les Yvelines est-ce
que vous comprenez cette prise de
position de la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France je la comprends elle
défend les Franciliens
c'est tout à fait normal elle est élu
pour ça moi en député rural de Normandie
je vais défendre aussi les Normands qui
ont besoin de se rendre à Paris d'aller
travailler avec des lignes parfois des
liaisons qui sont parfois longues
souvent en retard le train je le prends
quand même régulièrement maintenant pour
venir à Paris depuis Bernay je le
constate il est pas toujours à l'heure
et le trajet la durée de trajet bon
c'est pas ça d'autant que d'ailleurs les
trains qui circulent entre Paris et la
Normandie sont pas tous
au top de l'écologie il y a une grosse
partie de ces liaisons qui se font avec
avec du carburant parce qu'on n'est pas
doté de caténaire sur l'ensemble des sur
l'ensemble des lignes donc
moi je serai un peu entre les deux c'est
à dire qu'on a on a des lignes
aujourd'hui qui existent
créer de nouvelles lignes je ne sais pas
si c'est réellement indispensable je
pense qu'il faudrait d'abord voir pour
moderniser les lignes actuelles
éventuellement ils mettent de nouveau
train plus performant plus rapide
travailler d'abord cette partie là
plutôt qu'effectivement sortir tout de
suite plusieurs milliards d'euros pour
créer de nouvelles lignes
maintenant je me suis pas penché en
détail sur ce dossier là encore je vous
avoue
mais elle défend les franciliens et moi
je défends les Normands et si on peut
améliorer pour les Normands la
possibilité d'aller travailler sur Paris
ou soigner parce qu'on a beaucoup de
Normands qui vont travailler mais on est
aussi beaucoup de Normands qui vont
soigner à Paris parce que chez nous ben
on est dans un désert médical pour
soigner c'est compliqué notamment avec
des spécialistes donc moi je défends mon
territoire et la ruralité et si on a
besoin d'aller à Paris il faut qu'on
puisse le faire dans de bonnes
conditions et le fait que la première
ministre ils avaient de vendre soit
normande ça peut aider aussi dans dans
ce dossier pour la Normandie
Elisabeth borne elle est tellement
déconnectée du peuple que je ne sais
même pas si elle est encore connectée à
la Normandie donc je suis pas certain
que ça puisse aider malheureusement à
grand chose alors nous sommes le pays
européen ou l'essence hors taxes c'est
la plus chère entre le 21 février 2022
et le 1er mai 2023 le prix du sans-plomb
95 a augmenté de
12,5%, une augmentation difficile à
encaisser pour les Français qui prennent
régulièrement la voiture lors des
élections législatives vous militez avec
le rassemblement national pour passer la
TVA de 20 à 5,5% sur le carburant vous
n'avez pas été écouté par le le
gouvernement vous êtes élu dans une
circonscription où l'on prend beaucoup
la voiture vous l'avez dit déjà dans
cette interview quels sont les retours
de vos électeurs sur la situation
aujourd'hui quelques mois donc presque
un an bientôt après votre élection ce
qui il vous avait élu notamment entre
autres sur ces questions là sur le prix
de l'essence mais ils sont tout
simplement dégoûtés dégoûtés que je
parle pour ma circonscription dégoûté
qu'à 54% ils ont choisi Marine Le Pen à
la présidentielle qu'ils aient lu un
député rassemblant national et
qu'aujourd'hui le rassemblement national
malgré sa position de premier parti
d'opposition ne soit ni écouté ni
entendu par le gouvernement qui
considère tout bien faire ils sont
dégoûtés de se voir confisquer je mets
des mots à ce que je dis parce que c'est
le jeu de la démocratie c'est toute la
France qui va mais vous me parlez du de
ce que me disent les habitants de la
circonscription ils comprennent pas ils
sont dégoûtés de se dire à 54% on a voté
Marine Le Pen on doit faire avec
Emmanuel Macron il ne vous écoute pas il
ne fait rien sur les carburants
et en fait les les habitants de la
circonscription ils ont tout à fait
compris qu'Emmanuel Macron quand il
gouverne il gouverne en parisien
bunkérisé ils seront pas compte que
comme vous l'avez dit et comme je l'ai
dit plus tôt dans la circonscription
pour emmener les enfants à l'école pour
aller faire les courses pour aller chez
le médecin pour aller travailler on
prend la voiture
on n'a pas de tramway on a pas de métro
on a quelques liaisons de bus mais qui
vous emmène pas au travail et donc tous
ces tous ces habitants sont dégoûtés
j'ai aussi une part de personnes qui
n'ont pas voté pour moi et qui me disent
régulièrement mais la prochaine fois je
vote pour vous et je vote pour Marine Le
Pen parce que vous êtes les seuls en
réalité à proposer une vraie solution
sur les carburants et pas que sur les
énergies en général et vous n'êtes pas
suivi je vais prendre un exemple tout
bête ce week-end au commémoration une
personne est venue me parler et venue me
dire pourquoi on baisse pas la TVA sur
les carburants j'écoutais c'est ce qu'on
proposait
ils ne veulent pas le faire donc elle
m'a dit qu'elle était dégoûtée pour ça
et puis elle me dit et puis c'est pareil
l'État dépense 40 milliards en bouclier
pour l'électricité le gaz mais moi ma
facture elle a augmenté en mode février
donc je lui ai expliqué que oui on
dépense 40 milliards mais que malgré ses
40 milliards il y a une augmentation de
15 % en février et donc j'en ai profité
pour lui rappeler qu'on rassemblement
national on avait des propositions aussi
sur l'électricité et le gaz qui ne coûte
pas 40 milliards qui ne coûte rien et
qui permettent de sortir de cette
spirale infernale des prix des énergies
donc les habitants en réalité ils sont
juste dégoûtés ils ont compris qu'on
était dans l'opposition et qu'on ne
pouvait pas décider et ils ont compris
mais ça c'est Emmanuel Macron à coup de
49,3 que le gouvernement était
totalement sourd pensez avoir raison et
vivait dans une tour d'ivoire
[Musique]
toujours avec Kevin mauvieux député
rassemblement national de la troisième
circonscription de l'heure et membre de
la commission des finances de l'économie
générale et du contrôle budgétaire alors
dans ce cadre vous avez travaillé sur un
rapport sur la dette française alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu montrer donc
au cours de ce rapport mais j'ai pu
montrer ce que beaucoup de personnes
savent déjà c'est à dire que la dette de
l'État français est extrêmement élevé
elle est abyssale on a dépassé les 3000
milliards de d'euros
c'est important de le dire parce que
très souvent c'est une tactique
gouvernementale très souvent on parle en
pourcentage de PIB les gens n'y
comprennent absolument rien on leur dit
qu'on est à 111% de dettes ok 111,6 à la
fin de du PIB de 2002 et là les gens
vont regarder avec des yeux des yeux
énormes et vous disent mais c'est quoi
concret donc concrètement c'est 3000
milliards d'euros de dettes qu'on a
dépassé
c'est du notamment si on prend le budget
en cours un déficit de 156 milliards
c'est à dire que c'est comme aussi pour
illustrer les choses que les gens
comprennent bien et c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire dans mon rapport et
c'est ce que c'est un des points sur
lesquels j'insiste c'est le fait que les
finances publiques et notamment le
financement de la dette aujourd'hui
c'est très opaque pour les gens on
utilise des termes très techniques alors
qu'on pourrait vulgariser facilement
c'est comme si vous vous aviez 1500
euros de salaire pour le mois de juin et
que vous décidiez comme ça de dépenser
2500 euros voilà vous dépensez 2500
euros puis au mois de juillet mais vous
faites pareil puis au mois d'août vous
faites pareil à un moment le banquier va
vous dire non mais stop on arrête et bah
ce qu'on fait en France c'est que on a
un budget et pour cette année on va
dépenser 150 milliards d'euros qui
n'existe pas et ça on le fait depuis des
années et c'est dangereux ce que je dis
dans le rapport et je vais d'ailleurs
vous donner une information en avance
dans quelques secondes ce que je dis
dans le rapport c'est que la dette de
l'État elle est abyssale et qu'en plus
elle est mal structurée dans notre dette
en France on a 10% de la dette qui est
indexé sur l'inflation pareil les gens
vont dire ça veut dire quoi
tout bête vous allez faire un crédit à
la consommation ou un crédit immobilier
votre banquier va vous dire je vous
propose un crédit à 2% de taux d'intérêt
c'est comme si vous donc c'est ce que
fait l'état français vous lui disiez non
non on ne parle pas taux d'intérêt le
taux d'intérêt je vous rembourserai le
montant de l'inflation à la fin du
crédit donc dans 30 ans je ne sais pas
de combien sera l'inflation si elle est
10 %, je vous paierai 10 % de taux
d'intérêt c'est dangereux et ridicule
donc aujourd'hui les 3000 milliards
demain ils pourront valoir beaucoup plus
une part 10% donc on a environ 250
milliards d'euros de notre dette qui est
indexée sur l'inflation et l'information
que je vous donne c'est que je suis en
train dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
le printemps de l'évaluation de pousser
mon rapport un peu plus loin sur un
sujet précis et ce sujet précis c'est
les OATi c'est ce dont je viens de vous
parler la partie de la dette qui est
indexée sur l'inflation je pousse mon
rapport pour démontrer que la dette est
très mal gérée qu'elle est abyssale et
très mal gérée et un exemple tout bête
c'est que en 2020 on est en 2023 donc en
le taux d'intérêt que l'État a remboursé
sur sa dette il a été de 35 milliards
supérieurs à ce qui était prévu en début
d'année et je ne parle que du taux
d'intérêt remboursé et ça c'est à cause
de l'inflation c'est à dire que l'année
dernière on en avancé 35 milliards
d'inflation aux banques cadeaux en taux
d'intérêt sur la dette que la France a
contracté on est quand même avec 35
milliards pour vous donner une idée 50
milliards c'est le budget de la défense
c'est à dire qu'on a presque le budget
de la défense qui passe juste dans cette
partie de taux d'intérêt donc mon
rapport et bien il démontre tout
simplement que l'État est très endetté
trop endetté on l'a vu il y a pas
longtemps on a une dégradation de la
note par une agence de notation une
dégradation de la note par une agence de
notation qui est Fitch qui nous a baissé
notre note sur la dette souveraine de
l'État français donc voilà tout est dit
la dette elle établissa elle est elle
est trop élevée mal géré avec cette
partie de dette indexée sur l'inflation
il faut absolument corriger le tir
de façon urgente et
le tir ça veut aussi dire maîtriser le
budget de l'État on ne peut pas
continuer à vivre avec 150 milliards
d'euros de déficit tous les ans alors
justement pour les prochains budgets
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez des
restrictions budgétaires si oui dans
quel secteur bah des économies on peut
toujours en faire alors la première
chose que je préconise c'est d'arrêter
de s'endetter avec des oatti il faut
qu'on arrête ce système de de dette
indexées sur la flexion encore une fois
l'année dernière 33 milliards qui nais
35 milliards qui n'étaient pas prévus
dans le budget et qui correspondent à
l'inflation de ces de cette partie là
vous imaginez que sans cette partie là
de la dette ont gagné 33 milliards
d'euros sur notre budget c'est presque
le montant du bouclier tarifaire du
gouvernement c'est extrêmement important
donc déjà arrêté avec les OATi ensuite
il y a des mesures d'économie évidemment
on a par exemple pris à plusieurs
reprises l'exemple de la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État ou en tout cas de
son aménagement qui peut nous faire
gagner entre 2 et 5 milliards d'euros
par an on peut également prendre
l'exemple de la fiscale et de la fraude
sociale justement Gabriel Attali
d'annoncer un nouveau plan justement
pour donc récupérer un peu plus d'argent
sur la fraude fiscale et sociale
exactement il arrive un petit peu à la
traîne ça fait des années que Marine Le
Pen en parle on a déposé une proposition
de loi à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
quelques semaines à ce sujet-là donc
c'est peut-être ça qui fait qu'il se
réveille d'ailleurs mais on a déposé une
proposition de loi il y a quelques
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale les
économies qu'on peut faire en
travaillant réellement sur la fraude
fiscale et la fraude sociale elles sont
monumentales la fraude fiscale ça peut
aller jusqu'à 100 milliards les
estimations sont assez larges c'est
assez difficile d'avoir un chiffre
précis ça peut aller jusqu'à 100
milliards d'euros d'économies donc quand
on vous dit que l'État français il est
bancal par an de 150 milliards d'euros
avec la fraude fiscale vous montez à 100
milliards d'euros d'économies ça plus la
fin des eaux ATI où vous gagnez 30
milliards vous êtes à 130 milliards donc
vous voyez équilibrer les choses c'est
pas si compliqué que ça et après à côté
de ça mais il faut redynamiser
l'économie il faut refaire venir des
entreprises en France industrielles
j'entends ça ça passe par les circuits
courts ça passe par la priorité
nationale un exemple pour la priorité
nationale parce que on va nous dire
qu'on fait des grandes phrases mais il y
a des exemples dans ça doit être en
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes si je me trompe pas
il y a une ancienne centrale nucléaire
qui a été arrêtée qui n'existe plus
reste le bâtiment mais il y a plus de
centrales nucléaires à l'intérieur ils
vont en faire une espèce de champ de
panneaux solaires
bon c'est bien c'est un produit
d'électricité c'est très bien ils
avaient le choix entre commander les
panneaux solaires à une entreprise en
m'excuserait j'ai plus le nom de
l'entreprise en tête mais à une
entreprise qui est la seule d'ailleurs à
fabriquer des panneaux solaires français
qui se situe à quelques kilomètres de là
et commander les panneaux solaires en
Chine puisque sinon c'est la Chine café
l'État français il a commandé pour
plusieurs milliards pour plusieurs
millions les panneaux solaires en Chine
l'entreprise à côté reste sans commande
de l'État ça c'est un exemple typique de
de
l'idiotie on va dire de fonctionnement
des ministères aujourd'hui qui se plie à
cette règle d'aller acheter en Chine au
lieu d'acheter en France alors qu'on a
du génie français j'ai un autre exemple
de ma circonscription à faire du
localisme là pour le coup dans l'exemple
dans l'heure à Bernay vous avez une
entreprise qui s'appelle protecop qui
fabrique des gilets par balles des
équipements de protection pour les
militaires les policiers et les
gendarmes
cette entreprise
elle espère mais c'est pas sûr elle
espère bénéficier des futurs contrats du
ministère de l'Intérieur il y a quelques
années le ministère de l'Intérieur a
acheté pour plusieurs millions de gilets
par balles pour rééquiper les
gendarmerie protecope évidemment a
répondu à l'appel d'offres le ministère
a acheté ces plusieurs millions de
gilets par balles à une entreprise
située en Irlande une entreprise Irlande
qui assemble des pièces qui viennent des
quatre coins du monde alors que proteop
fabrique tout de bout en bout à côté de
Bernay dans l'Eure c'est encore une fois
un exemple et le problème en France
c'est que on ne fait pas de priorité
nationale et dans les choix qu'on fait
on inclut pas les entreprises françaises
et l'exemple de protecope c'est que en
réalité protecop a expliqué comment
fonctionne son marché en comparant avec
l'Allemagne en Allemagne quand
l’allemagne va commander des gilets par
balles elle va réunir l'ensemble des
industriels allemands elle va leur dire
je vais commander des gilets pare-balles
avec tel type de typologie pour que ce
soit bien précis et difficile à copier
et elle ne le dit qu'aux entreprises
allemandes ce qui fait que le jour où
elle fait son appel
que l'Europe oblige à faire son appel
d'offre en disant j'ai besoin de tels
gilet par balle les entreprises
et nous en France on ne consulte pas nos
entreprises j'aimerais pour finir cette
entretien Kevin mauvieux parler de votre
première proposition de de loi avec
votre homologue donc marine hamley
député du Tarn-et-Garonne vous avez
déposé donc une proposition de loi
visant à éloigner des auteurs de
harcèlement scolaire donc lorsque les
faits sont commis en état de récidive et
légal à suspendre certaines prestations
sociales alors selon un rapport du Sénat
au niveau national le taux de
harcèlement scolaire et de 6% autour de
6% un phénomène déjà bien connu mais qui
peine à être totalement endigué
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux chez les
adolescents à accentuer aussi la gravité
la longévité de ces phénomènes alors
comment comptez-vous y faire face donc
avec votre proposition de loi alors ma
proposition de loi elle se elle se
découpe donc en deux volets comme vous
l'avez dit le premier volet alors j'ai
envie de dire ma proposition de loi elle
vise à éviter la récidive et à protéger
les victimes plus qu'à lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire en lui-même en
l'attaquant de cœur parce que le
problème est plus complexe vous l'avez
dit maintenant il y a les réseaux
sociaux etc donc ça on y travaillera
évidemment mais ça prend un peu plus de
temps là c'était une proposition de loin
un peu dans l'urgence
notamment suite à l'affaire du petit
mail qu'on a tous vu dans les médias ou
vous avez et je l'ai appris grâce à
cette affaire vous avez aujourd'hui un
système en France ou quand un enfant est
victime de harcèlement scolaire
c'est lui qui va quitter l'établissement
souvent avec un document du médecin
parce que malheureusement ça atteint
psychologiquement l'enfant c'est lui qui
va quitter le système scolaire le
harceleur lui continuait à l'école
l'enfant lui il est privé de scolarité
et en plus il est privé de lien social
parce qu'il ne peut plus voir ses amis
donc il est dans une espèce de double
voire de triple Pen donc ma première
mesure elle vise à remettre un peu de
justice au milieu de tout ça à partir du
moment un enfant est harcelé on ne doit
pas lui imposer d'autres peines que
celle du harcèlement c'est au harceleur
de quitter
on ne va pas le décoller le déscolarisé
évidemment donc on l'envoie dans un
autre établissement mais c'est au
harceleur de quitter l'école et à la
victime de pouvoir continuer sa
scolarité de pouvoir continuer à se
construire avec ses amis et ça me semble
extrêmement important humainement
parlant et puis la deuxième partie du de
la proposition de loi elle elle vise à
éviter la récidive parce que dans les
entretiens que j'ai pu avoir notamment
avec Hugo Martinez qui gère
l'association Hugo il y a beaucoup de
récidivistes malheureusement et en fait
je pars du principe que quand votre
enfant harcèle à notre enfant à l'école
c'est possible avec responsable aussi
alors vous êtes responsable aussi mais
la première fois on n'est pas dans
l'antre de l'école on sait pas ce qui se
passe et je j'imagine que ça peut tout à
fait passer à côté de parents qui sont
tout à fait convenables que leur enfant
harcèle à l'école voilà on est dans un
milieu de plus en plus difficile en
revanche une fois que votre enfant a été
condamné ou que vous savez qu'il a un
potentiel pour être harceler scolaire
c'est à vous en tant que parents de
remettre en place les mesures éducatives
qui sont nécessaires à son encadrement
et à le faire retrouver à lui faire
retrouver le droit chemin donc à partir
de ce principe là j'ai effectivement
fait cette seconde mesure de ma
proposition qui est de suspendre entre
deux et six mois les allocations
familiales ou certaines prestations
familiales aux parents de l'enfant
concerné c'est l'appréciation du juge
qui en fonction des situations voient
parce que peut-être de certaines
situations seront beaucoup plus
complexes que ça mais il faut envoyer un
signal qui est de dire un enfant harcelé
est une victime on en prend soin on le
laisse dans son cocon qui est l'école
avec ses amis on éloigne le harceleur et
si il y a récidive on met les parents
face à leur responsabilités il peut y
avoir deux à six mois de suspension de
certaines prestations familiales justice
équilibre défense des victimes et on ira
plus loin prochainement après voilà il
faut qu'on leutionne il faut qu'on
réfléchisse dans d'autres propositions
pour lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire en tant que phénomène merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle donc que vous êtes député du
rassemblement national dans la troisième
circonscription de l'heure nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebdopolitique très
bonne soirée à tous
nos politiques